this video is sponsored by Best Buy
hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where today I thought that I
would do something that I haven't done
in a while a big old haul video with
these boxes behind me I worked with Best
Buy to get a big old bunch of cool stuff
that I thought might help anyone looking
to buy gifts for some of the PC gamers
in their lives specifically for the
holiday season I have 10 things to show
you today so let's jump into it
this is the Asus G14 AMD ryzen 9 gaming
laptop I use a version of this almost
every single day the Asus G14 is an AMD
Advantage laptop that is built for Best
in Class gaming with exclusive smart
performance Technologies and a premium
display all powered by the ryzen 6900hf
processor and Radeon 6700s graphics it
has MD smartshift Max technology that
dynamically ships power in your laptop
to help boost performance for gaming
which is definitely helpful for someone
like me who travels a ton it means I can
still stream and play games while
traveling without sacrificing Graphics
or performance while on the go but what
about somebody who already has a PC or a
laptop I think it'll make you like the
coolest family member or friend ever
if you gave them one of the next few
things that I'm going to show you
because most people would never expect
it but almost every PC Gamer will want
to use it they are never not useful so
this could be very cool first up very
simple this is the WD black P10 portable
game drive I have been using WD black
drives for a long time and the WD black
P10 game Drive gives you a PC or console
worth noting the performance enhancing
tools it needs to keep your Competitive
Edge it is built specifically for gamers
looking to expand the potential of their
console or PC by saving their game
library in an on-the-go form factor a
game Drive is always very handy I
promise but if you want to seem even
cooler this is a gaming disc as it's
called basically it's an internal SSD
this is the WD black
sn770 nvme internal SSD the sn770 is
very simple it boosts the storage of
your gaming PC with rapid boot times and
quick access to files plus it looks so
nice I love this design again extremely
useful I feel like every PC gaming is
guaranteed to want to use one of these
and if they don't have one already the
great thing about storage is people can
always use more I also think an extra
cool thing about WD black as a brand in
general is that their stuff just looks
cool it's gonna work with almost every
PC build it's gonna look really really
nice they really make them sleek and
stylish and fit with a modern PC but I
want to love you also another SSD
because there is a lot of variety in
this particular Market
and they do different things so this is
the Samsung 980 Pro internal SSD as you
can see two very different designs as
well as different features of course
Unleash the Power of the Samsung 980 Pro
internal SSD for Next Level Computing
the 980 Pro delivers two times the data
transfer rate of pcie 3.0 while
maintaining compatibility with pcie 3.0
it also has one terabyte and two
terabyte size capacities available this
one is a little tougher to show you
because it
because it's sizable
very exciting under any kind of festive
holiday tree that you might have at home
this is the Samsung 27 inch g-sync
gaming monitor again just box size for
reference it's not small but what's
inside is beautiful the Samsung Odyssey
has a 240 hertz refresh rate lightning
fast one millisecond GTG response time
and full adaptive g-sync compatibility
and freesync premium support so you can
be sure that the Odyssey G4 won't let
you down I've been a fan of Samsung's
gaming monitors for a really long time
and I would say actually most content
creators I know use them in my
experience they're just really high
quality with great designs and solid
functionality for everything you might
need next up because a lot of Gamers
have really Tatty headsets I was using
an out of date one for years before I
finally got a replacement because we
just don't think to replace them
ourselves weirdly most of the time next
up is a headset and this is a fantastic
pick this is the Corsa hs80 RGB wireless
gaming headset like half of my gaming
setup is Corsair the hs80 RGB wireless
gaming headset brings superb audio
quality utilizing industry-leading
Wireless technology you can even turn on
Dolby Atmos it also utilizes corsa's
slipstream Wireless technology providing
low latency high quality audio because
it's important for a wireless headset
the battery life is up to 20 hours and
it has up to 60 feet of wireless range
and I will say because I know it matters
to me I imagine it matters to a lot of
Gamers I tried it on and this one is
really comfortable as well so nice
cushioning around the ears and that
headband feels great
okay the next one is also from Corsair
and um while it may require slightly
more research to make sure that it'll
work with your PC Gamer setup again
definitely something that when I was
looking at these I was like oh this is
such a good pick to show people because
if you ever buy this for somebody they
will think you are the coolest person on
the planet I have this picture of when I
was like 14 and I wrote uh on my
Christmas list of birthday lists that I
really wanted a graphics card so that I
could run PC games better I didn't get
that can you imagine if I had gotten
this not a graphics card but so cool
literally super chill this is the Corsa
Elite LCD liquid CPU cooler and it is
beautiful the Corsa iqh 150i Elite LCD
is an AIO water cooler that delivers
powerful customized cooling for your CPU
with a personalized LCD display the LCD
display is the absolute coolest thing
about it I can't show it to you but you
can like add text and memes and stuff
onto the actual LEDs if you want which I
just think is such a cool way to
customize a PC it's awesome it has a
high performance pump head with a ring
of 24 individually addressable RGB LEDs
it comes with three included 120
millimeter Corsair ml RGB Elite magnetic
levitation fans with 8 RGB LEDs per fan
and air guide technology Channel airflow
for extreme PC cooling performance the
Corsair IQ software enables you to
switch between a variety of display
options such as fan speeds you can also
adjust fan and pump speeds and control
and synchronize RGB lighting with all IQ
compatible devices it's very modular and
has a tool-free mounting bracket and
elongated tubing for quick and painless
installation on all modern Intel and AMD
sockets including lga1700 one two
hundred one one five x 2066 and am4 also
worth noting that it has a 5 year
warranty
something that is very nice to upgrade
you just have to take a look at
somebody's setup and you'll know
these things get dirty this is the g815
white SE keyboard which is actually
exclusive to Best Buy and is so pretty
so clean the g815 white SE keyboard has
a Sleek impossibly thin yet durable and
sturdy design the g815 brings Gamers to
a higher dimension of play with
programmable G keys that let you create
and execute complex actions simply and
intuitively it also has a volume wheel
and media keys to give you fast easy
control over video audio and streaming
this is the Pro X Superlight SE red
mouse and this thing is like very very
very light like it's hard to believe
that there's anything in this box this
one is also exclusive to Best Buy the
Pro X Superlight SC red mouse has
precise fast and consistent control with
hero sensor it was designed in
collaboration with the world's leading
gaming Esports Pros engineered to win it
is the Pinnacle of the company's
continued Pursuit for the highest
performance level and while all that is
very impressive my favorite thing about
it definitely is how light it is it's
light it feels really Compact and Sleek
but it doesn't lose any functionality
even with that cool design I just love
the way this looks I'm
not going to recommend to go with all of
this
without any of it and it is especially
useful because even if somebody already
has it you can add more and there's no
way they won't appreciate that and that
is PC game plus three month membership
theme you can play over 100 high quality
PC games with friends on Windows PCS for
one low monthly price with games added
all the time you'll always have
something new to play for recent games
definitely want to give a personal shout
out to pentiment and plague tail Requiem
I think that they are both absolutely
wonderful and for pentiment specifically
it probably couldn't exist without game
pause so it's definitely worth checking
out and there you have it this is a
pretty broad range of products All
Things Considered so I'm sure you'll be
able to find something that works for
the gamer in your life and remember Best
Buy has everything you need to game your
way and lots of options to get you what
you need fast they offer one hour
curbside pickup which I use all the time
free next day delivery on thousands of
items and even some options for same-day
delivery which is awesome thank you all
for watching I hope this was helpful to
some of the people who've been asking me
these questions I'm very happy to have a
video to link you full of awesome
recommendations otherwise I'm Alana I
will see you next time bye